when you got the tattoo was there a
moment while you're there in the chair
getting it that you had like a pang of
regret or no you it was almost like an
affirmation yourself that if I had this
there's no going back uh no there wasn't
there wasn't a pang of regret until I
stopped working and then I was like damn
I got this tattoo and then you know it
became something that I look at and I go
yeah I got this tattoo so there was
maybe a moment after when I stopped
working as much I was like oh man but
then it started to be like no this is
this is why I got to wake up every day
and go to meetings and this is why i
gotta you know continue to hustle
because it's a grind and to truly be a
filmmaker you have to be the type of
person that you know when you get that
phone call like i was talking about
where they say hey do you wanna do you
want a regular job like that's going to
pay you a salary or do you want to make
this little indie film that's not going
to pay you any money because i never saw
any money off of my pure joy I never
made it sent but you have to be the type
of person that when you answer that
phone and they ask you that you go no I
want to make the movie because at the
end of the day that's that's that's what
a filmmaker is you're the one it's it's
it's insanity it's literally insanity
but you have to be that kind of insane
so tips for hibernating I think that's a
beautiful like way to put it because
there are you know days when you're
getting emails and all sorts of stuffs
happening and then there's just times
when you can't get arrested it dries up
and it feels like there's a conspiracy
against you and so when you go through
those hibernation type x what are some
tips for other people that they should
know for the winter see I'm totally
learning about this now too because it's
the first time it happened to me so what
I've learned is one of my one of the
things I really learned and this is
gonna sound really silly and I probably
shouldn't say it but don't continue to
spend money as if you are making the
same money that you were making because
I was like well I would probably get a
job in the next three
week so don't don't continue to just go
out and run ridiculous bar tabs and
stuff like that be be more conservative
don't eat out every night also go out to
as many industry type events as possible
network as much as possible talk with
people and what I've learned is at this
level unless you're making a studio film
you're an indie filmmaker and if you're
an indie filmmaker at this level we are
all on the same playing field I don't
care if you're doing you know million
dollar movies or if you're doing movies
on five hundred dollar budgets you're
all struggling and you're all making
these movies so at the end of the day
talk with other filmmakers talk to
people and unless they're a jackass
they're really approachable I respond to
people on my Twitter I have a hundred
thousand followers on Twitter I respond
to every single one of them every time
they ask me a question i get i get
messages and emails all the time from
fans asking you know how do you how do
you go out and do this and why do you do
this and that's one of the reasons why i
made my movie to jennifer on a five
hundred dollar budget on an iphone 5
because i wanted to show people that
it's possible as long as there is a good
script you don't need a crew you don't
need anything except the phone that was
you know the the most accessible camera
the thing that's in your pocket you can
pull it out and make a movie as long as
you have a good story and that movie
ended up getting rave reviews one me a
bunch of festival awards and you know is
on DVD and it's been distributed and
stun decent and at the end of the day
that that shows you that you still flex
your creative muscle when you when you
hit hibernation don't don't take that as
a as an insult against you and the
world's against you take it as time to
hone your creative process you can sit
there and you can write you can sit
there and create you don't have to stop
creating and at the end of the day we
have a responsibility once we become
creators to try and inspire others to
create
because my film school not only was
making movies but my film school was
watching movies I grew up watching
movies I watched movies all the time I
would come home every day my dad was
sick he was in a hospital bed for most
of my childhood after that he was
bedridden at home and he was on a bunch
of drugs he had to have a liver
transplant he was you know dying of
hepatitis C and the only thing that I
could do with him was watch movies and
that's what i would do every day I'd go
to it go up to his room upstairs sit
down watch movies and we talked about
him and you know movies became my life
and at the end of the day film is
something that people can share and we
have a responsibility as the people that
create to inspire others to create so
that the people that are listening to me
talk about going out to make movies are
one day the people that are saying you
got to go out and make movies because if
not then there's no such thing as a film
Renaissance there's no such thing as
film being created it just dies we have
to go out and inspire and if we don't
inspire we're not doing our jobs
correctly so use your time in
hibernation to inspire others and to
talk with others and you never know when
you're talking to other people maybe
they have a project that you're right
for maybe maybe you can start developing
something with that actor that's been
hitting you up all the time to do
something with them you never know but
don't don't just turn somebody down just
because they're eager to work with you
because if they're eager to work with
you that's awesome if they're not eager
to work with you you're the eager person
hitting them up so put yourself in that
position and and realize that it's our
job to inspire others just so
everybody's where my dad is still alive
he had a liver transplant and we
actually wrote a script together
recently and we're going to write
another one together so it's it's been
really great being able to collaborate
with one of the most talented writers
I've ever known
you